foreign
this is the Ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions it's the Ramsay show where
America hangs out to have a conversation
about your life your money your work
your careers your relationships whatever
you want to talk about we are here for
you I'm your host George Campbell host
of the fine print and entree leadership
podcast joined today by fellow Ramsay
personality Dr John deloney best-selling
author host of the creatively named Dr
John deloney show John how are you
George excellent George if I turn the
the microphone on he's learning doing
great man how are you learning I'm
excited to take some calls today help
some people let's do it let's go let's
go to the phone lines open phones triple
eight eight two five five two two five
is the number you give us a call we'll
talk about whatever you want to talk
about Jeff joins us in Pittsburgh Jeff
welcome to the Ramsay show
good afternoon gentlemen how are you
today great how can we help
okay so I'm 53 years old
um I lost a 34-year job to covid in
2020. I've recently found another job
but unfortunately I'm kind of in a
depressed area where I live and I had to
take a job a similar job but I'm making
less than half of what I what I worked
my way up to in my previous job I have
some cash savings I live in uh
I have my home I own it flat out I paid
it off from 14 years took a 30 out
played it in 14. awesome very frugal I
live way below my means I'm very cash
heavy I have a small IRA
and moving forward I'm just not sure
which direction to go with my earning
power being a lot less than what it had
been Jeff what were you doing before you
got laid off
I was a GM at a independent uh
independent owned dealership car
dealership ah okay
um
and car dealerships have just been a
mess the last couple of years yeah yeah
what are you doing now
I'm a GM at an auto repair facility okay
so what were you making what are you
making now
uh well I made my most money in my
entire life
um I made like 70 000
um from 16 to 2020. that's the most
money I ever made in my life four years
in a row that's what I made now I'm
making like less than half of that I'm
I'm working salary I'm going to make
about 34. wow
is there room for this to go up if the
car market kind of Trends back
well working for a repair facility not a
car dealership anymore so I'm sure the
car dealership's going to rebound and
I'm just wondering I mean you can make
you can make more than that in a
different career altogether with your
experience
out there this I'm about an hour north
of Pittsburgh is not a really great job
market where I live
um I've looked I've been looking since I
got hired to be quite honest with you
because I knew I wasn't going to be you
know happy sitting where I'm at
but I guess my biggest question is I
want to talk today was
um about the money that I have and where
I should what in this situation what I
should be doing with it I but before
George jumps into that I think the a key
about where you're going to put your
money is is how long term or short-term
is this situation
and are you going to move are you going
to I'm going to use a word here that's
got a clinical
component to it and I'm not meaning that
here when we go through what you went
through with your job loss there's some
data out there that tells us that's akin
to losing a loved one
and we often don't grieve it that way we
just get pissed off and then we grind it
out and have to go get in the truck
because we gotta eat and when our spouse
passes away we know we got to take some
time and process and grieve this and
it's hard and it stinks you got to sit
in it and then you gotta decide what's
next and often we run and
man you're worth more than thirty four
thousand dollars and I don't mean that
in a in a spiritual sense but no no I
understand it took me 34 years to get to
that point though there was many many
decades where I made 30 40 you know 50
grand
um but those years honestly I I
discipline myself to save money and get
my house paid off yeah it's incredible
what you've done yeah it's it's
remarkable you've done
it's just gonna when the fog lifts here
or when you start
um leaning into okay what's this thing
actually going to look like for me if
you make peace with 35 Grand your GM of
a place you love it man I'll high five
you all day long but George is going to
talk about the Investments and where to
put Park your money and stuff but man a
lot of that's going to depend is this a
temporary situation for you are you
going to sell this house that you've
lived in move somewhere and I don't
think I'm gonna sell my house oh gosh I
love my home I love where I live okay
um I have two elderly parents in the
area I'm probably not going to move okay
so that's that's helpful and so you've
resigned yourself this is it and I live
in a in a depressed or dying Community
but we're gonna if I can make 35 I'm
gonna make 35 I just got to figure out
what's I'm not saying that's not going
to go up a little bit but I don't think
it's going to double okay okay okay so
let's talk about the the financial
aspect here how much cash do you have
uh a little silent 450. 450 000 in a
savings account where is this yep yes I
have it in savings account you've done
incredible yeah way to go you're an
absolute rock star what's in the ira
uh well up until a couple days ago
probably uh probably right around 100.
what happened a couple of days ago
I think the market cropped in it
I think the market took a little hit
didn't it yeah a little bump nothing
nothing wild I mean you shouldn't lose
half your money in there but I don't
know I didn't say half but I'm gonna say
what probably a little less than I had
last week but um yeah probably right
around 100 Mark okay and what's the
house worth
250. awesome dude are you are you a
millionaire brother are you getting a
millionaire not yet you're getting there
yeah net asset yeah I have some you know
I have a you know I guess I'm close
that's awesome Jeff you are a
millionaire
sit in that for a second okay right you
know what I mean and you made that you
topped out at 70 grand you've bucked
every Trend available uh what a absolute
stud man it's incredible so this 450 000
I want to put it to use I don't want it
just sitting there in a savings account
uh do you have any retirement options
other than your IRA
uh I do not that's everything I just
told you is what I got um I have some
other small assets that you know add up
to a little bit more cash but I'm I'm
not planning on casting them in unless I
have to but I don't I own everything I
don't own anybody I don't own a credit
card nothing awesome well dude this is
this is good news I definitely want to
put this to work and let this money grow
for you so you can have an awesome
retirement so I'm gonna take take
advantage of every tax advantage
retirement account I can before moving
into you know taxable Investments and
just a general brokerage account if
you're investing in index funds or
mutual funds so that you can let that
money grow I would connect with a smart
investor Pro if you aren't already
working with a financial advisor that
you love that's got the heart of a
teacher and they can walk with you for
your specific situation and tell you
exactly where this money is going to be
best put but I don't want it sitting in
a savings account for sure because were
you just saving up for rain today before
this all happened you know I was earning
a decent amount of money every month on
that account when I was getting almost
three percent on it but now it's getting
you know 0.55 yeah well even three
percent if you can get eight nine ten
eleven twelve in a good growth stock
mutual funds I'd rather you be doing
that and this money can grow too you
know what kind of risk level is that
because I'll be honest with you I'm not
medical investor I'm not I'm not Savvy
on that at all well that's right yeah
well there's always risk but if you're
doing mutual funds you're very
Diversified we teach four different
types our smartvest for pros can walk
you through all of that help you explain
it and you'll still be in control you'll
be making those decisions just jump onto
ramseysolutions.com connect with one uh
we're rooting for you man you're doing
well sorry about the job loss but life's
not over you got a long way to go way to
go man this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
a career in technology I recommend
Bethel Tech and I'm not alone here's
what brynden said before Bethel Tech I
was driving Uber within four months of
graduating I got a job paying sixty
thousand dollars about two years after
that I got a remote job that pays me a
hundred and thirty thousand dollars all
thanks to what I learned at Bethel Tech
you could be next get started today at
betheltech.net and get one thousand to
twenty five hundred dollars off of your
tuition again it's
betheltech.net Ken Coleman
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
open phones this hour the number to call
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five
it is time to put 2021 behind us last
year left a lot of people feeling burned
out and sluggish Eeyore was their spirit
animal but 2022 is a fresh start and
this is your wake-up call if you're
ready to own this year and actually
accomplish your goals with money your
career and life we have the plan to get
you there you can make 2022 your best
year yet and we're running our new year
sale right now where you can get up to
73 off our best-selling books
assessments and envelopes that includes
Dave's brand new book a number one
National bestseller baby steps
millionaires that will show you the
quickest right way to become a
millionaire
or if you're looking for a better way to
manage your cash especially in the
categories that are always blowing up
your budget like food pick up our
popular essential cash envelope systems
maybe you're having a hard time bouncing
back from the last two wild years you
should start 2022 with our best-selling
quick read from my friend Dr John
deloney by my side here redefining
anxiety he's going to teach you what
anxiety is what it's not and how to get
your life back best part it's only 10
bucks that's a pretty good deal visit
the online store ramseysolutions.com
backslash store to get serious and make
real progress I'm George Campbell joined
by Dr John deloney today open phones
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Darren joins us in Alberta Canada
Darren welcome to the Ramsay show
hey how you guys doing today great how
can we help
so
I am just starting out as a young family
I have one little kid 22 years old and
has absolutely zero
[Music]
um
Financial
sort of Savvy if you know what I mean
I'd never learned how to treat money I
could have saved a ton when I was
younger but didn't you said you're 22.
we're stuck living
22 years oh you you act like you were
like a very old man with no time left
yeah all right that's what it kind of
feels like most people wish they were
starting Yet brother you're good man I
don't know that's kind of why I'm trying
to turn this all around because at the
moment
how things are going it looks like I'll
be working till I'm 80. wow well we can
change that I don't want to do that why
do you feel that way what's your
financial situation do you have a lot of
debt
I unfortunately we did well actually
fortunately we do not have much only
about two grand okay uh in credit cards
just recently starting to look into the
baby steps but every time we try to get
our thousand dollar
uh emergency savings put down
uh since it's winter with covet my hours
are cut there's no work really going at
the moment so we end up cutting into it
just to pay our ordinary bills we don't
eat out we don't spend extra money we
don't do anything
and like I've already started doing
running doordash and
taking on as many extra side jobs as
possible just to make sure we have
enough
how can we
set like how can we change things enough
what do you do for a living man what's
your day job
I want a hydrovac truck
for an environmental company like you'd
think you'd have a little more work but
winter has
almost no work and competition is
beating us out yeah so what do you make
a year man
about forty thousand forty thousand is
that all the household income
yes my wife doesn't work we have a
little boy at home and uh
yeah so you owe two thousand dollars
yeah okay managed to wheel it down yeah
so I'd like to get rid of the credit
cards entirely oh absolutely absolutely
so I'm gonna let George walk through the
baby steps but I want to back out 30 000
feet okay
okay
brother you're in a you're in a better
spot Than You Think You Are
you're it's cold and it's been dark the
last few months and you sound beat down
how old your baby
Eve eight months eight months so I want
to tell you I've got two little ones
myself it's you're in the season of
eight months when it's exhausting you
can't go outside because it's zero or
it's negative zero Where You Are
all this weighs down on you what the way
that I hear in your voice is a like
you're under one of those anxiety
blankets those weighted 50 or 80 pound
blankets or 40 pound blankets and like
your soul has left you you are not in
bad shape financially brother you are
way ahead of the game
I think the question you and your wife
need to ask yourself is is this where we
want to live
if this is going to be their financial
reality of the the job I work in now and
by the way since I was 22 I probably had
five to six to seven different jobs a
couple of different careers so you're
you're good man
but I want you to look at this with
optimism not with it's all coming down
because you're 22 man you are just
getting started and you only owe two
grand the number of calls we get from 22
year olds who owe 100 grand
is is is astronomical right so you're in
a good spot I want you to look at this
through
um Joy not through it's all over is that
cool
okay all right good foundation there so
Darren uh it sounds like to me that you
don't have a lot of margin in your
budget every month
I've actually never even made a budget
well every day is the day my friend I'm
gonna hook you up with Ramsay plus
that's our year-long membership and it's
going to get you connected to every
dollar a budgeting Tool Austin will pick
up after our call is over and get you
connected with that I also want you to
go through the Financial Peace
University videos with your wife do this
as a family start budgeting and you're
gonna see where your money's going
because right now it sounds like you're
not really sure why there's no money
left at the end of the month and so I
want to know exactly where that's going
we did crunch it all together and we did
figure out exactly how much more we
would need to accomplish just the bills
good
and here you might need to pick up some
extra side jobs you may need to
supplement that find something you're
good at and go see if your neighbors
need their driveway shoveled I mean it
can be anything get creative this is not
forever it feels like it is but this is
a short run at the moment actually even
make donuts on the weekend just to cover
up that's awesome at some point you're
gonna have to have a hard conversation
about is this the job for you a job that
doesn't offer any work in the in the
winter time that doesn't sound tenable
or sustainable and if competition's
eating your company alive it may be time
for you to say okay in two years where
do I want to be do I want to be a nurse
practitioner in five years I want to be
a nurse in two years do I want to own my
own truck in three years do I want to
have a mechanic shop whatever those
things are start planning for those
things now
um
but man there's a lot of yeah we've
already done this we've already done
this you gotta start this thing with
your attitude brother and say sweet this
is falling apart sucks now I'm on to the
next now what's gonna what's you know me
what's gonna happen be there for me and
my family go get it man yeah you're 22
with two grand in debt you're gonna look
back at this six months from now and
you're gonna be out of debt you're gonna
be working on that fully funded
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses and then you're not going to be
worried about the hours and what's gonna
happen you're gonna have what we call
Financial Peace and after that you're
going to begin investing and and saving
for that that kids college and paying
off the house early and doing all kinds
of amazing things and so I want you to
dream about that future and let that
Vision fuel this fire uh where you go
you know what I'm gonna do whatever it
takes right now yeah I'm gonna look back
and say remember when things were crazy
and my job there was no hours we were
doing whatever it took to get by and
those are the stories you're gonna be
able to tell your son and so get plugged
into the stuff we'll have Austin pick up
and make sure you get connected to
Ramsay plus and that will walk with you
along this journey to make sure that you
know exactly what the right next step is
perfect thank you for that Darren good
call John yeah man man but it is
interesting that the 25 year old guy who
thought my life's over yeah I have two
grand in debt I thought he was gonna say
I'm 64. I have nothing in retirement I
lost my job and I have a hundred
thousand dollars in debt and almost
almost all of the time I hear somebody
with that level of
despair yeah there's there's life
circumstances going on somebody's
marriage is in trouble someone's got an
eight month to hold and they're in the
doldrums of winter in Canada right
whatever it may be and it's easy to see
a little road block a little speed bump
as this Giant mountain and it's just not
you just gotta back out far enough and
go all right man I thought this was
going to be it I'm 22. dude I was a high
school coach when I was 22. and since
then now I have a YouTube show I mean
who knows where this thing's going yeah
uh but you got to get out there and
hustle and you got to say all right this
isn't working this ship has got a hole
in it so I gotta get another boat and go
find another job yeah and that's a great
reminder for anyone listening because no
matter what age you are you always feel
like it's too late for me right right
and I've I mean I'm 42 and I just lost
my job and I'm I'm 18 and I don't know
what I want to do with my life all over
it's not it's never too late start over
again yep start over again 70 just start
over again just keep getting back up
keep getting back up keep getting back
up good reminders there this is the
Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
chaos that's what it can feel like when
your business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by Oracle including Ramsey
Solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory HR planning budgeting and more
All in One dashboard go to netsuite.com
Ramsay right now to get their free white
paper jump start your CFO career
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show I'm
George Campbell Ramsey personality and
host of the fine print podcast joined
today by my friend Dr John deloney host
of the Dr John deloney show both of
those shows you can find on the Ramsay
Network or wherever podcasts are found
open phones this hour it's a free call
Triple eight eight two five five two two
five let's talk about your money your
life your relationships your career
whatever keeps you up at night your
fears your dreams your nightmares John
is not afraid to go there and he will
let's go to Josh in Fort Bragg North
Carolina Josh welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey gentlemen thanks a lot for having me
absolutely how can we help
talking about your fears in life so I
feel like it's a great introduction here
perfect bring it on come on dude I'm
active duty uh Army uh my wife and I and
two kids are stationed at Fort Bragg and
um we're brand new to starting Financial
Peace we started about uh Christmas the
last year and um
I felt like we've always been uh
financially Savvy
um but until starting your course uh
it's figuring out that um uh I've got a
negative net worth that was uh pretty
revealing
Josh first uh man brother thank you for
blessing me and my family with your
service I'm grateful for you and dude I
remember distinctly one of my best
friends in the world's name is Todd he's
a banker when he did my net worth with
me and it was negative and he laughed so
hard he almost threw up his laughing so
hard I was in disbelievements I remember
that moment man it's a good friend I'm
pretty good I'm pretty good nope not
well hey that's step one that's right
that's right that's one you're doing
great so what's your circumstance
brother
yeah so
um
famous Christmas well November of last
year
um I bought a 2022 Toyota 4Runner
attaboy they always make the bad
decision right before they join
Financial board I love it okay right
before attending right all right
it's about a forty seven thousand dollar
truck
I financed 37
um and I had 20 000 in the bank
and so of course very first thing after
we started doing Financial Peace
um also my wife was pretty apprehensive
about it I threw all about a thousand
dollars at it and so I only I've got 17
000 remaining on it now the where where
things get a little bit scary or sketchy
for me is
um I've got uh attending religious
exemption
um with with this coveted vaccine and uh
the threat is rooming that they're going
to separate those of us that get denied
exemptions in June or July
and so
um I can I'm paying off right now about
3 200 a month towards this truck
um our our net take-home is about 5300 a
month
um so it's 17 000 owed on this I can
have it paid off in about five and a
half months or should I sell the truck
and I could get about thirty two
thousand dollars in Pocket by a twelve
thousand dollar
you know get completed you can only get
32 Grand for this truck I guarantee you
can go on that guarantee no no sorry
maybe maybe I um didn't Express the the
numbers right so if I if I can sell it
for 50 yeah yeah
you will net you're saying you'll net 32
Grand exactly I'll net 32. and then
what's what I spend let's say ten
thousand twelve thousand on a on a
vehicle that's safe for my family and
then I've got back to having 20 000 back
in the in the banks for you know our our
three to six month
um emergency funds if you separated it
June and July are you gonna lose this
income
yes and that's and that's where that's
where things are scary for us because
okay I mean what's your household income
uh so right now
um while I make gross 5400 but we live
on base so I bring in uh 3 500 because
they take away your your housing yeah
your housing pay right this car feels
like it's a large part of your world net
worth income
the car yeah
yeah and that's the point it's like I
mean I I feel the whole reason we bought
this vehicle is because you know I've
I've tinkered around on eight thousand
ten thousand twelve thousand dollar
vehicles in my life's like hey I'm tired
of driving these and so you know like I
just finished a special operations
training here and so I'm thinking oh man
I'm just just rode the bus straight to
entitlement and was like yeah I deserve
this nice truck yeah and now dude
there's there's nobody no group of
people that I know of that are more
awesome more brilliant and make more
ridiculous car choices than my friends
who are in the service
like and you know that dude hey at least
you didn't get a Jeep with big tires so
you were the family car so good for you
Josh let's skip to the good stuff yeah
Josh sell the truck man yeah I want to
take the what might happen in June or
July off the table okay okay that's
clouding this thing
you might lose your income and there's a
reality to that and if you think in any
job for any reason that hey come come
summer I might be out of a job then
obviously you need to be doing what's
best for you and your family like what's
that going to look like how am I going
to earn a living all that let's take
that off the table right now
George just nailed it this is a this is
too much car for your household income
right now whether you had this or not
you got a 50 000 car and a sixty
thousand dollar income it's it's too
much as is so I would I would tell you
to sell it if you told me I got into
special ops team I'm gonna get deployed
but I'm gonna be there for the rest of
my life and make it 65 Grand I would
tell you to sell the car anyway
and I know your wife doesn't want to
keep driving that I get that
um yeah y'all just it's just that y'all
have a dollar amount situation that you
got to deal with a reality you gotta you
gotta think about it this way uh you
said you're tired of driving the car but
you're about to be tired of being broke
man and I'd much rather you be tired of
driving the car and so make a good
decision for your family one day it can
be your goal to get that car again when
it makes sense for your income and your
family but right now you got a mess to
clean up appreciate your service man
appreciate you brother all right let's
go to Amy in Dallas Texas Amy welcome to
the Ramsay show
hi guys how are you great how can we
help
um so I
am in baby step seven
um
32 years old so George
boom we're the same boat
yeah you're incredible
yeah and so now I have I have seven
brothers and sisters and I'm second to
the youngest and so I'm trying to figure
out
how do I get them to take my advice
oh you figure this out Amy you'll be a
billionaire yep the short answer is you
don't uh and I can tell you that my
oldest sister shout out Melissa good job
but uh my oldest sister is I got her the
uh Dave's latest book babysit
Millionaires and she said every dollar
app has been a lifesaver and she's now
got her husband on board so I'm so happy
I'm so ecstatic
and my adult nieces and nephews I think
I can convince them like if I get them
the the team stuff that you guys offer
but I want everyone in my family to just
be able to feel how life-changing it is
to be financially free and be able to do
whatever you want so Amy
Dave's talked about this his he's got a
number of family members that that don't
even do this program
and I've got family members that I've
bought the books for and they don't do
the program so
um the reality is you can't you you
can't be responsible for extended family
members taking feeling the peace and joy
that you have what you can be
responsible for is you living that out
every single day so they're around you
they see the kind of piece you have they
see the good decisions you're making and
you hope that people go hey I want some
of that what is that and then you've got
a copy of Total Money Makeover or baby
stuff millionaires you can hand them and
then say if you want to know more let me
know right yeah I mean you've got a lead
by example and they've got to get to a
point where they're in so much Financial
pain they go well Amy has so much peace
I'm just gonna all right fine like
they're gonna give in eventually maybe
and maybe they don't maybe they don't
maybe they live their whole life and
they never follow this stuff
um and and you gotta love them
regardless that's how family is and I'm
I'm in the same boat I've got family
members who I'm like oh my gosh how are
they not doing this stuff right but the
best thing I I can do is just lead by
example and be encouraging to them in
their situation and only offer help when
they ask for it but me going to my
family giving them unsolicited advice
about their financial situation like
they're not calling into the show
they're not interested in my advice
right so you you are amazing and they're
gonna look down and go wow 32 years old
with a paid for house if Amy did it
maybe I can too I'm gonna ask her how
she did that and that's the key
[Music]
so keep plugging along but if you figure
it out how to convince everyone around
you will write a book we will write a
book together I love it this is the
Ramsay show
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George camel
host of the fine print podcast season
one available now on Ramsey Network and
wherever you listen to podcast joined
today by Dr John deloney who does his
show way more often are you guys uh like
three shows a week now John yep we're
running man wow well I'm enjoying it
team's doing a great job you're doing a
great job I appreciate people this is
more long-form mental health
relationships boundaries a lot of things
that we touch on on the show but you go
deep with collars yeah and I love the
way you do it uh you do with humor you
do the format it allows for a little bit
longer conversation but yeah I would
love it man so check that out on YouTube
or podcast wherever you like to check
out that stuff uh we're going to the
phones now free call Triple eight eight
two five five two two five Miriam joins
us in Sacramento Miriam welcome to the
Ramsay show
hi gentlemen I have a question uh
surrounding what I need to do or what
would be the best financial thing to do
with regarding uh home purchase my
husband
unexpectedly passed away three months
ago I'm so sorry Miriam I'm so sorry
thank you he was uh 57. uh what did he
pass away from
goodness gracious I'm so sorry
um I'm going to be 53 next month we had
already planned on
uh we both had pensions at our company
and we had already planned on retiring
at the end of this this year and we um
we were going to be actually moving to
East Tennessee as a matter of fact and
um we
you know we had set ourselves up
financially for that and um with
pensions and 401ks and whatnot however
now I'm in a situation where I do want
to still continue that plan although now
I want to move it up by a couple of
months so right now I'm thinking
probably
um september-ish time frame and my
question is because now I have
approximately 650 000 in life insurance
and and both of our 401ks which I
realize I can't touch all of mine now
um because of my age but
um I am trying to figure out
if it is uh better Financial sense to go
ahead and purchase a home in Tennessee
with you know some of that money and
um that way I don't have a contingency
when I go to sell my home in California
or wait and go ahead and sell you know
in the summer early fall time frame use
the equity from my home which I estimate
to be somewhere around 350 to 400 okay
and then use that to purchase a home in
Tennessee at that point
um what's the rush to get what's here in
Tennessee
uh the Russian well for one I just want
to retire which was what we were like I
said planning on doing this year anyway
sure we were both ready
uh Tennessee is closer to where I grew
up in Indiana okay but it's also
um where uh two of my one one daughter
and son-in-law are planning on going and
they have grandkids so then I have
grandkids and they have the children so
then that way I'd be close to them okay
so so can I I'm gonna say some things
that are hard okay is that okay
yes okay
so man this you're obviously your love
of your life passes away suddenly at 57
um that's I mean the devastation there's
is clear right and we all experience
that what most will blow by and I know
is Weighing on you heavily is
y'all had plans
yep you did like you all breathe the
same air and when you how long were
y'all married
uh 18 years married 20 together there
you go so I mean you were together for
two decades so he's an arm and a leg of
yours at this point and vice versa
and y'all had plans
and the decoupling that loss and that
grief and that I'm the heartbroken I've
lost my life partner I've lost half of
me is one thing
and then having to do the hard work of
saying we had plans together but what
are my plans going to be going forward
and what I've seen over the over the
past two decades is people will try to
continue the plan that quote unquote we
had
and then get somewhere and realize this
isn't what I want to do with the back
half of my life and you're only halfway
done sister right yeah right you're
halfway done and so
the the the generic common wisdom I tell
anybody is don't do anything for six to
nine months or a year and just sit the
what's complex about that is you live in
California you know you want to leave
and I want to high-five you there too
right so it's a little bit faster were
you telling me hey I've got grandkids
I'd want to make sure they're going to
move there before I packed up and you
know what I mean so there's a lot of
moving variables that man we can go all
in when it's both of us because even if
the kids don't show up forget you guys
we're living East Tennessee it's
beautiful it's cool we don't have income
tax
if you're now moving because they
they're probably going to move there or
maybe or you see what I'm saying
it's a shame
um company system that we are currently
in and I'm in they're going anyway and
it's largely due to obviously the State
of the State of California
um and what's being shoved down all of
our throats so so why not move next
month it's just a matter of when oh yeah
no I and so I should have qualified for
this one because
immediately right now I'm looking to
wait and make my decision until uh
probably
um April may-ish and the reason for that
because my son-in-law will be finding
out around that time if he is able to go
ahead and move to a sister company there
so okay okay so again they're still
gonna they're still going to go
regardless so my thing too with moving
out of California is when I moved here
from Indiana I never planned on staying
more than a year or two but I got into a
retirement system that has you know been
very gonna be very lucrative for me but
I have not wanted to stay here for the
30 years I've been here I've been
itching to get out and now I'm finally
at that point where I'm old enough to
retire mostly due to my husband with
military pension and you know just
regular pension and that sort of thing
so I'm blessed in that sense great but
I'm ready I've been ready to go we were
ready to go but I've been ready longer
than him because I've been in California
longer not wanting to be here if that
makes sense you know I love it I love it
so Mike George speaking of this I I
would take that life insurance money and
park it in a simple Index Fund if you're
going to buy a house over the next six
months I would sit it right there
I would love to see you sell your house
and take that Equity to buy a house
instead of holding two houses and have
something happen in the interim yeah
exactly I would wait until your plans
are more firm sell the house I would use
the equity and with the life insurance
money like John's saying I would invest
that with index funds or you can work
with a smartvester pro and they can walk
with you through the best way to invest
that money so that you know that life
insurance is made so that you can live
off of that money in case something
happens and so we want to make sure it's
invested wisely so that you could peel a
certain percentage off of that every
year and use that to supplement your
income so that you can have a great
retirement
if that's your plan so you you have an
automatic draw out of his his
401s and whatnot right
uh currently I'm only receiving his
pension because as it stands stand right
now because I'm still working 100 time
I'm hoping that's that I don't have to
dip into any of that great so and that's
worth a morning you know in California
so when I go to Tennessee
and effectively have no mortgage I'm not
going to have to to touch the four ones
or life insurance or anything so you'll
just live off the pension so that's so
that then they change it if you get some
firm plans here in in a couple of months
with your in-laws I mean in your in your
kids
um then yeah if you've got the pension
set up to where you're living off that
money and you want to go ahead and buy
I'd be okay with that if you if you've
got this steady income stream coming
through I would do it with cash you have
the money I would purchase a home in
cash when you do decide to move and uh
you know with that life insurance being
invested it's still a wise idea and with
that 401k you may want to look at
rolling that over to an IRA so that you
have some control over that so I would
work with a financial advisor just to
walk with you through this process and
make sure that you know the Legacy that
you guys have built with this money is
is well spent well taken care of well
invested yeah we absolutely love you and
we'll be with you all every step of the
way here so don't don't hesitate it
calls back I would love you to see you
the next three months start dreaming
about what do I Miriam want this to look
like yeah and that's going to be hard
and heartbreaking and grief-filled but
also beautiful and optimistic enjoy
filled as you begin to turn that new
corner of what the rest of your life is
going to be heartbreaking stuff yeah
that puts this hour of the Ramsay show
in the books are thanks to Ben running
the board today Austin phone screening
and Kelly Daniel our producer we'll be
back with you before you know it
[Music]
[Music]
have a friend or a family member that
needs a daily dose of Ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
Ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the Ramsay
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is the Ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions it's the Ramsay show where
America hangs out to have a conversation
about your life your money I'm George
Campbell your host joined today by
Ramsay personality Dr John deloney it's
a free call phone lines are open triple
eight eight two five five two two five
you give us a call and we will talk
about whatever you want John is a wealth
of knowledge and I'm just here for
entertainment should be a good time
that's a low entertainment bar really
low knowledge bar but it's Friday Dave's
gone he's probably golfing because the
calls are free that's right you have
nothing to lose except time exactly we
got plenty of that and a couple of brain
cells give us a shout all right let's
see what Rob has to say in Philadelphia
Pennsylvania Rob welcome to the Ramsay
show
hey how are you guys great how can we
help today
uh I'm in the middle of baby step two
while also saving for a wedding and uh
congratulations
thank you thank you uh I have a car
that's fully paid off that I paid 16 and
a half for and it's now worth 19 and a
half
so I was thinking of selling that using
that uh money to finish off the wedding
savings which is only three thousand and
then I wanted to attack my student loans
with the rest of that but I wasn't sure
how much to save for another card how
much do you have in student loans
uh 26 000. and you need to save another
three for the wedding but
uh three thousand is left to save for
that how soon is the wedding
uh it's in December oh okay you got
plenty of time bro save your money keep
your car dude
really
convince me otherwise
the car here's the thing when it comes
to selling the car it's not going to
create any cash flow
because you don't have a payment on it
so it's not going to make you money
except for what you get for it and uh
you're still gonna have to go buy
another car in this market which could
be you know eight ten Grand right
right which leaves you with 10 grand
after all said and done and all you know
all the effort you're putting into
selling this car so the question is can
you save up 10 grand and avoid having to
sell the car quickly what's your income
uh 50 000.
okay and what do you have in debt total
is it just the student loans or is there
something else
no just the student loans okay
well
um do you know if your fiance has debt
uh she's dead parade awesome
well
making 50k you're going to easily be
able to save up the 3K for the wedding
right
right we'll put that in savings are you
guys paying for this all on your own
uh a third her parents the third my
parents and a third of us okay and she's
chipping in some and you're chipping in
some here you're you're part of 3K
that's left okay
I think you can save up for this wedding
and then go hard on the student loans
until the wedding happens
what what is it what is it about this
car you want to sell it
um I was just thinking that would be the
quickest way to get the student loans
out of my life and then I could just get
by with a cheaper car for now
do you have a cheaper car in mind
uh no but I was looking in like it seems
like before in this market is like three
to five thousand
yeah everything's awesome like a Fred
Flintstone car with no engines three
thousand bucks right now pretty much I
don't have a problem if you want to sell
a car you don't want it anymore and it's
going to clear all of your debts and
whatever and you can go get a car that's
going to get you from here and there
that's not gonna hurt my feelings
yeah my other thing is that I work from
home now and I don't really use the car
as is okay
yeah well then man sell it I mean like
George said you're not going to be
solving a long-term problem but I do
understand the impetus to feel like I
could expedite the next year of my life
pay off my student loans go into my
marriage debt free pay for the get the 3
000 bucks for the wedding yeah
yeah I mean if I'm in your shoes
personally I would sell it yeah I would
too because I don't care about driving a
nice car my car cost six grand I've
driven for five years now I have no real
intention or urgency to get a new one
and I just tried to sell my car to
George off air but that's for between
four and eight thousand making deals
we're not car guys so I mean I love the
the hustle from Rob here wanting to get
the cash wanting to pay down this debt
quickly and really setting yourself up
for some amazing success in marriage
when you guys start this thing off debt
free if you can do that so I'm all for
it but there's no fire where I'm going
dude you got to sell the car so it's
your decision either way and if it's
going to give you the motivation to get
rid of this debt fast then I'm for it
just know what you're trading um you're
going to be trading a 17 000 car or
twenty thousand dollar car basically for
whatever you can scrounge together for
eight to ten Grand it's a good question
congrats on the wedding man Amber joins
us in Indianapolis Amber welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hi thank you for taking my calls today
absolutely um
yeah
last year and we're sitting at like baby
step four
um we're both in our early 30s I was
kind of getting the mindset of preparing
financially for kids in a house within
the next few years but we've both only
rented and never actually owned a house
so we're trying to get ready to prepare
for a down payment and pay for that but
a savings account and a CD just they
feel stable but not necessarily a lot of
room for growth
um and like sorry they're cutting out
Amber speak directly into your phone
that's okay sorry about that so yeah
you're saying you want you want to see
some growth here you don't want to just
park it in savings and watch it move at
a half a percent yeah and I looked over
little bit into rocks by arrays and saw
you know obviously you know the the tax
part of it where you're not necessarily
getting taxed on withdrawals but
um and there seemed to be an exception
for first-time house buyers to take I
think up to ten thousand dollars in
earnings
um and you could also take contributions
out but just wanted to get your guys a
sense of if a Roth IRA is a beneficial
way of doing it and also while also
getting that growth
um especially if we're looking to
purchase within let's say the next three
to five years okay well I would not
recommend saving up for the house in a
Roth IRA that is a retirement vehicle
and there are just better options out
there one would be an index fund that's
a simple way to save up for for a house
that's going to grow and you can invest
in some great great index funds there
and when we were saving up for a house
we worked with a smart investor Pro we
put our money in some good growth stock
mutual funds and that really helped us
for those few years that we were saving
up so if you're talking a three to five
year timeline I'm totally good with you
you investing that money and if there's
any like urgency of hey we need to do it
in three years and I would say hey you
might want to look for a safer solution
like a high yield savings account but if
we're talking three to five years and
you've got some wiggle room there I
would be parking in index funds or
mutual funds in just a taxable account
not a Roth IRA yeah think of it I like
your analogy George think about it like
uh
maybe at the beginning of the year when
people were struggling to find rental
cars and they would just go get a U-Haul
box truck and drive it across country to
wherever they were going instead of
renting a car a vehicle will get you
there that's not the right vehicle yes
right it's uncomfortable it's the
chances of it things going sideways it's
just not the right car yeah and you can
invest in in the same mutual funds that
you would in your Roth IRA there's some
great options out there that will still
give you you know a 9 10 11 12 we're
seeing some great returns obviously
lately in the market and that could
change but if you've got a three to five
year time Horizon the roller coaster at
the end of the day will still have
trended up but if you're telling me you
want to do this a year from now well we
could see a down Market a year from now
and you've lost money and now you're
trying to get this house but I love the
spirit of you guys wanting to make sure
that you're doing this wisely and the
best way to do it is with index funds or
mutual funds and uh you can get
connected with a smart investor programs
and solutions.com and they can help you
get all of that sorted out great
question this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
how'd you guess with health care costs
Rising learn how Christian Healthcare
Ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
[Music]
foreign
there is a lot of hype going on in the
real estate market right now buyers are
feeling the pressure to buy and to buy
right now and with all the talk about
interest rates going up buyers are
frantic to lock in now our rates are
hanging out in the two percent range
don't get me wrong race probably won't
get any cheaper than that but that
doesn't give you the green light to do
stupid as in buying before you're debt
free or with a zero down payment or
offering way over asking price and
waving inspections stuff like that is
high risk can always cost you in the
long run it's easy to get caught in the
hype but get your head out of the
craziness for a second and look at the
facts are you debt free do you have a
down payment of 10 to 20 percent can you
afford home ownership a mortgage
insurance taxes maintenance if and only
if your answer is a big fat yes to all
of those questions does it mean that
buying a home is a smart move for you
right now
once you've answered those questions
it's time to look at some cold hard
numbers and one of my favorite tools is
our free mortgage calculator tool at
ramseysolutions.com free tools you can
see exactly what your home ownership
options are based on your budget even if
you're not there yet start dreaming
figure out what those numbers are for
you you can go to ramseysolutions.com
and click on free tools and check out
the mortgage calculator open phones this
hour triple eight eight two five five
two two five Ken joins us in Seattle
Washington Ken welcome to the Ramsay
show
hey Dr John and George how are you guys
doing today doing great how can we help
yeah I wanted to run by a home purchase
question for you guys oh perfect start
yeah I was just talking about my wife
and I were we're thinking about uh
having another child and so we're
looking for a bigger space
and that part's pretty straightforward
the income part is there's a tiny
wrinkle there I have I work in big Tech
so about half of my income comes through
the form of equity and stocks they're
granted to me but they don't invest
month to month sometimes they vest maybe
once a quarter
and so my question is I just wanted to
run through some numbers with you guys
to see if this upcoming home is stupid
or if it makes sense this is a fun game
Let's Play hit us with the numbers
okay so right now the home that I live
in it's about 1600 square foot it's
fully paid off and it's worth around 900
000. fantastic that I'm looking to
purchase is going to be around 3 000
square foot so a little bit less than
half or double the space and it's going
to float around 2 million
okay
the income is five hundred thousand a
year 250 of that comes through the form
of equity and so for me I feel a little
bit uncomfortable going 15 years I was
thinking the monthly uh the mortgage is
going to be higher than 25 of my take
home so one idea I had was working a
30-year just to lower the monthly
payments but then at the end of the year
dumping all My Equity right into the
principal and trying to pay off the
house in about four years even though
I'm having a 30-year mortgage
hmm what is driving the urgency right
now like how how long could you wait
technically before jumping into a new
house
well we're thinking about trying for
kids probably in the summer so that's
probably the biggest Factor it would
just be a little cramped we could still
make it work but you know another fear
is also that prices are going to go up
sure well but and your house would go up
too so right it would it would they move
together
walk me through your your Equity plan
um it sounds like you're it's more of a
bonus structure than an equity plan or
do you sell your Equity every year
yeah so how big Tech works is for your
compensation there is stock that is
awarded to you you don't pay a dime for
it it's not like an employee purchase
program you can sell it right away if
you want or if you hold it it can
potentially grow correct the company
that I work for is a publicly traded
company it's been around for 20 years
and the stock grows at about 30 a year
so I've been holding on to it and I can
sell at any time essentially so I I
George and pushed back on push back on
me I don't want to consider that
take-home pay
so I don't if you making 500 000 a year
you get 25 uh 250 000 in cash to take
home
um Let me let me take it out of big Tech
and give you an example so when I worked
at one of the universities I worked at
part of my package came with a salary
and it came with a home because I'm on
campus in the middle of the night 24 7
365 and it also came with my kids could
go to college for free okay or at some
discounted rate
when I put that on paper my total
compensation was
was robust
but I couldn't count that in my I can't
send that IOU to my my electric bill
right or to my mortgage company so I've
got to sit down and look at how much
cash am I getting every month you see
what I'm saying so I get the total
compensation I wouldn't factor that into
my home purchase price unless you want
to go ahead and sell what you've got and
liquidate it and have a million dollars
I don't know much Equity you've built up
in your
um in in the company Equity but if you
want to sell that now and cash it out I
I guess you could do that but do you see
what I'm driving at
I think so yeah just the fear of losing
your job and then not having those
stocks actually best
but if you have a paid for two million
dollar house we were not really worried
about stocks at that point
so I'm wondering how much how much
stocks could you sell off right now how
much could you make
I have about 750 000 worth of stock but
based on the trend that it's growing
that can easily Blossom to A Million by
you know September and in big Tech it
could easily go to 250 000 by September
too is that fair
I don't I mean based off the trends for
the past five to ten years it's Amazon
so it's been doing great okay okay yeah
I mean I I understand I'll give you
Amazon but you know when you're you're
asking us should I take out a million
dollar mortgage and the I can't in good
faith tell you to do that even with your
amazing income but if you're saying hey
you know I could sell off 400 500 Grand
in stocks to where it would be 25 of my
take-home pay on a 15-year fix that's
what I would be doing if I was in your
shoes I would be saying how much stock
what what's the least amount of stock I
can sell off to where this is the right
financial decision for my actual reality
take-home pay does that make sense
yeah that doesn't make sense and and I
think the part that I've probably left
out is I have 20 saved in cash right now
so 400 000 and I was going to sell this
home and put that all towards the
principal so I wasn't oh you'd have 1.3
to put down
well now they've got a whole different
equation because now you've got a 700
000 mortgage with 250 000 a year salary
yeah just in cash yes right yeah I still
I still would play around with that
calculator make sure that it's 25 or
less so that you know you have the
margin to pay this thing off early which
you're going to be able to do and you're
going to be you know a multi-millionaire
if you're not already uh which is
incredible so you've done really well I
just want to make sure that we don't
step into a decision quickly and you go
oh my gosh I can't breathe I got a
million dollar mortgage right now I
would sell off just enough stock to
where I could get it under 25 and then
aggressively attack that thing
so 25 is kind of the Baseline no matter
what it's it's the ceiling essentially
exactly yeah I mean if a 25 and a half
percent we're not going to yell at you
this is a guideline this is not you know
uh we're not trying to be
fundamentalists here I just want to make
sure that we make a decision that's
right for your future and not just for
your present
and this is going to set you up in an
amazing way no it's uh yeah
congratulations
34. holy crap wow my man is crushing it
way to go fantastic and again I
Georgia sounds when we tell somebody
who's making that kind of money with
that kind of return
that the principle still applies like
even though the numbers get get to be
Monopoly money that the principles still
apply
is we say this all the time but math is
math is math is math and
I always go back to my mom worked for
Enron dude and it was the Amazon of the
day it was the biggest company it was
massive it was doing all the stuff and
then one day it just didn't exist is
that rare of course it's rare
um but when you've got a fully paid for
900 000 basically million dollar house
you got 400 Grand in the bank like man
take your time and do it right yeah and
don't get over creative the thing I want
you to recognize here man uh Ken is
you're gonna have to make a concession
on one of these things you can't get all
of the growth and buy make a super safe
smart purchase and you're gonna have to
concede on one of these so it might be
I'm gonna concede a little bit of the
stock and the growth it might or might
not happen for what I know is to be a
safe purchase to put me in my family in
the best long-term position and look at
it this way if you had five hundred
thousand dollars cash would you go I'm
going all in on Amazon stock probably
not exactly so that tells me I'm okay
selling off that much to make sure that
I get into this house and there's no
Financial stress in our family only
financial peace but way to go Ken 34
years old multi-millionaire I love to
hear that it's awesome man this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George
Campbell joined today by Ramsey
personality Dr John deloney and we are
taking your calls phone lines are open
the number to call is triple eight eight
two five five two two five Rafael joins
us in Palms Palm Springs California
Raphael welcome to the Ramsay show
hey how you guys doing doing great how
can John and I help
good so I had two questions so the first
question was I wanted to know how not
having a credit score would affect your
interest rate on a mortgage and then the
second question
um has to do with building a house over
buying a house so my wife and I we live
in California right now we're looking to
move out of state within a couple years
and we're looking to move to like
Oklahoma Tennessee uh Missouri something
like that somehow somewhere where it's
kind of cheap to buy land okay and so we
were wondering if it's better to buy a
house already or to save up money
and to kind of just go through a home
construction process when we finally
find where we want to live well there's
pros and cons to both uh I'll tell you
me and John have vastly different
experiences he he bought a he bought
some land he's got a house I did new
construction uh in a in a Suburban
neighborhood here and so very different
experiences I like the new construction
process number one because it gave us
built-in time to save up because you
lock in the house for a certain price
and then you still have you know six
eight 12 months while they build it
before you close and have to pay up and
so I like that about it I do like that
you get to choose the fixtures and so if
you guys are very particular versus
having to gut a house when you get in
you say I hate the cabinets I hate the
carpets I hate the paint I'm not a DIY
guy John is you know America's chip gain
so he doesn't mind doing all that Chip
Gaines is America's chip gains but so
and hey I hate the idea of building
something that that makes me I've built
residents I mean built buildings in part
of my other jobs not single-handed yeah
yeah no been a part of the process with
Architects and man I'd rather just move
into a house that I love that's just me
and if we have to do some DUI stuff at a
house I I love that but yeah in Georgia
are just different so it's a personal
preference thing so on that side there's
pros and cons to both you got to stay on
top of the builders there's going to be
issues there's going to be things they
do wrong and so you have to babysit it's
like a part-time job to follow the
construction process and make sure you
know you're like a project manager in
that regard so there's nothing wrong
with either but you guys have to decide
what's right for you guys and on the
credit score side I actually did the
manual underwriting process on this home
and I had the same question as you
because a lot of people that push back
on our plan they go well you're going to
get a terrible interest rate and I
actually asked the lender I said how
does this work if I do manual
underwriting the no score loan how does
that affect the interest rate and they
said well based on your financial
situation if you have a good down
payment we basically treat your credit
score as good and I just did a refi on
my house and
did the same process and got a stellar
interest rate and I have no idea what my
credit score is yeah I haven't even
looked and so so it's it's a myth that
your your interest rate is going to be a
lot higher now could it be a quarter of
a percent lower higher I mean yes
there's variables in here uh but living
without a credit score is not as uh hard
as people make it seem I had a great
experience with mine there wasn't a ton
of extra paperwork involved it was a
pretty seamless process and Raphael you
asked a question about whether you
should buy a house now
and save up money to move later or to
just save up your money and rent now
walk me through that question one more
time
out of the state so we live in
California right now we're planning on
moving to a different state and wait
wait why don't you leave California just
kidding go ahead you know it's it's
absolutely perfect here but you know but
um do you know where exactly you want to
be because that's my only thing is I
would choose it more based on location
and do we have kids and where the
schools at and where's all the shopping
because we want to be around the action
I would base it more around that versus
are we going to buy new or or uh you
know pre-existing home
yeah so it's not necessarily buying new
it's all I guess I find new in the sense
of the construction part of it but
um it's more so my wife wants to have
like the house that she wants to have as
opposed to buying a house for all this
tons of amounts of money and then you
know having to fix everything how she
wants to have it you know so she was
thinking just going through the new
construction process
um and that we're getting to customize
the house exactly how she wanted to have
yeah my wife was the same exact way she
wants to choose the fixtures and the
flooring and what does this look like
and man I'll tell you I I never my brain
was wrecked trying to choose grout color
for like the seventh room and I was like
I don't even care anymore man it was
just so many details linoleum baby yeah
roll it out but uh either way it's good
but again this sounds like a personal
decision for you guys and it sounds like
you're leaning towards new construction
so that you do have more flexibility but
you might look around and go we found an
awesome house that we love as is or we
just need to paint one room and we're
good so do your research and make sure
that house is well under your your
take-home pay so that you guys aren't
underwater but from California to
Tennessee man you're good there's
freedom and money I love it all right
Ryan is on the line in Jupiter Florida
Ryan welcome to the Ramsey Show
thank you guys nice to talk to you today
how you guys doing you as well how can
we help we're good man
well this this may sound like a silly
question but my wife and I are both
retired we're totally debt free cars
house everything
and but we have this habit of three or
four times a week we go to our favorite
coffee shop which is has stores
worldwide and I drive up we order our
coffee I go to a driver's window they
scan my app and they give me my coffee
and after so many cups of coffee I get a
free cup of coffee and I'm doing this
right or should I pay cash or well
there's a simple framework for this and
I'm gonna just go ahead and guess you're
talking about Starbucks
well yeah okay okay
in Florida so that's why I guess we're
on to you Ryan I I do the same thing and
here's here's the easiest way to look at
it is it in the budget do we have a
coffee budget because we love coffee and
we're just gonna say we're gonna go
three to four times a week and we
planned for it or are we letting the
rewards Drive our spending decisions
that's that's the difference we have to
parse out
because truthfully that if that free cup
of coffee it's what two bucks I mean I
don't know what you're ordering a fancy
latte
no I just cut it off I had a boy Ryan I
had a habit of that a few years back in
the old Ramsey building I would stop
every day on my way to work and it was
budgeted for and I would get my Grande
black coffee for two dollars and 61
cents and you better believe that was in
the budget and so as long as it's
planned for you don't have to feel
guilty about it and the rewards you're
not going into debt for this coffee so
there's no guilt around the reward
system but don't let that drive you to
go I'm gonna spend 20 bucks at Starbucks
so I can get a two dollar cup of coffee
you know what I mean my other my other
side of the question is you know I can
download money into the app that I use
my credit card or instead of using hold
on hold on Ryan Ryan you're using a
credit card that was a stupid question
you want the cat out of the bag your
debit card yes just load it up man I
mean it just works the same yeah what I
do is I don't overthink it I keep enough
on there and then if I don't have enough
money for my next purchase I reload it
with another 10 bucks but I'm not going
to pre-load it with 150 either you know
yeah but if you want to pre-load it with
whatever's in your budget you save 50
bucks in the budget this month for for
Starbucks load it up man load it up with
50 bucks and if you run out sorry time
to make some coffee at home in fact I
could see that being a great way to
control overspending there right is I'm
gonna put my coffee Budget on this
prepaid app and when it's gone it's gone
right yeah I like that I'm with that
that's a great question though because
there is that there's still the mental
game and rewards and the gamification
this can drive us to make some poor
financial decisions well I could see
somebody who said okay I'm going to get
rid of my credit card with points
because I don't want to live the points
game and then go oh but I'm getting
coffee points over here is that okay and
one of those you mentioned it one of
these is going into debt with the
promise I'll pay you back in 28 days
this one is dude this is your money and
if you just keep being a repeat customer
we want to throw you a little cup of
coffee every once in a while I'm not
even really paying attention to if my
rewards are at the point where I get a
free drink once in a while go oh okay
you know my wife's getting a fancy drink
let's go ahead and use the reward right
that's another thing take advantage of
that you know if I get the free reward
it's good for anything at Starbucks any
so I make the craziest drink possible
just to make the Baristas mad I'm like
I'll do eight shots I'll take every pump
or whatever you got give me the fanciest
most expensive oat milk you have back
there I'm like cool that'll be nine
dollars I'm like sweet I'm using my
reward zero I don't ever make Baristas
mad because they control your life that
is true that is very true I'm not that
I'm not that sure eat your Baristas but
Starbucks has a range you can either get
a two dollar drink or a nine dollar
drink you get to make the choice I tend
to go to the cheap side John you know me
that's me too you know me black coffee
will do I'm there for the caffeine I
just get water from the hose out back he
likes a white chocolate mocha I'll have
you know America he's a fancy man
I love it good conversation not one that
anyone needs to have but we had it
anyways this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George
Campbell Ramsay personality and host of
the fine print podcast joined today by
my friend I think you'd call me a friend
Dr John deloney most days I do most days
today is that day and we are taking your
calls it's a free one triple eight eight
two five five two two five Melissa joins
us from Fort Worth Texas Melissa welcome
to the Ramsay show
hi thank you for taking my call
absolutely how can John and I help
hi um so I recently were I was looking
and I noticed a couple credit cards that
I didn't know about they those five of
them and the only person that I can
think of that has my social security is
my mother
I confronted her about these cards
um she confirmed that she took them out
I was not aware of any of this
um so I'm just calling to kind of just
give some advice on like what I should
do about this situation yikes
um what's your relationship with your
mom
um we're really close
um not as close as you thought
found out a couple weeks ago and so just
kind of figuring out what was her what
was her reasoning from for violating
your trust like this from stealing from
her daughter
she told me that they were kind of
struggling with money and
um at the time like my credit score was
actually you know decent
um and so she
chooses use like those credit cards that
you get in the mail type of thing
just kind of apply to those the easiest
way
um
any kind of addiction what is she
spending all this money on
um she was just saying she didn't I
didn't really in the moment I didn't ask
exactly why I was just kind of just hurt
by those situations
um but um she was just saying that she
was in a really bad place and just was
really struggling financially and
that's what she did
um so Melissa so I um I'm not going to
talk bad about your mom
I will a little bit but I I'm not gonna
I'm gonna talk more about this this full
picture here okay
okay your trust and the sanctity of your
Social Security number was stolen from
you and compromised a crime was
committed you got that
yes and I know that's hard but your
mother committed a crime and you are the
victim
and all right definitely yeah I was this
would be such a major trust violation
for me
because it was it was done behind your
back with full knowledge that they were
stealing from you and
um
there's two people on the planet that
can't ever do that and that's Mom and
Dad right
yeah yeah
so if I'm you I would
go to the Social Security number office
and change my number
I would tell my mom this is a major
trust violation major and it's gonna
cost you a bunch of of mess and if you
have to pay for it I would tell her
because you have I I've lost your trust
and I have to go do this I'm asking you
to pay for any of the fines and fees or
whatever it's going to cost to change my
social security number I would let my
mom know you cannot have this and if
there is any sort of anything then the
next step is I'm going to file a police
report and I know that sounds really
rough because that's your mom
but you've got to understand you are
simply responding to a crime that was
committed
and not like being ugly to your mom your
mom started this and now she dropped
this in your lap and you have to create
the boundaries and deal with this
yeah right and I know that's so hard
because you thought you had a good
relationship with your mom you're gonna
have to grieve that relationship because
it's not what you thought it was
and I hate that for you
it's okay
um it's hey hey no it's not it's not
okay
because I get how I mean I'm just
thinking if I was to show up and do this
I can't even wrap my head around how
heartbroken that would be if I found out
my mom had done this
yeah it's a big deal that's kind of what
I've been processing that's right
Melissa you also need to go ahead and
freeze your credit with all three
bureaus so that no one including your
mom can open any kind of trade lines
with your name and social security
number that is your A1 do you currently
use a credit card
yeah I currently have one and so so it
was like recently and kind of knew it
looking at my credit and stuff and so
when I saw the cards I was just like
whoa I almost got blood yeah and when I
saw the others I was like
yeah that's actually a great Point
George I would pull my credit is there
any other charges
like is there a home equity loan taken
out on with your credit card or is there
other lines of credit no no no no no no
I started looking at everything else no
it's just it's five cards okay how much
debt is on is on your account now
um all the cards collectively is about
six thousand okay well she needs to to
pay that off whether that's giving you
the money because you have access to the
account that's probably the safest way
to do it but I don't want these
lingering going to collections all under
your name on your record
so you've got some cleanup to do is she
gonna does she have the money to pay you
um that's what I had a conversation with
her about it I told
not I want I don't I personally don't
want to I feel like I shouldn't no no
you're not paying a dime of this no
you're that way you have 60 days to get
six thousand dollars or I'm gonna have
to make a police report because I got to
go get another social security number
and I got a file on my credit report
that these are fraudulent charges that's
what I would do yeah that's a firm
boundary and that your mom will say oh
my gosh you're gonna do that to us we're
struggling yes
because if you'd asked me for six
thousand dollars and so we are broke and
we are starving you might have been able
to help but you stole from me you stole
from me and now you changed the the the
relationship boundaries here
gee I'd give her a deadline I didn't
even think about that George I'm sorry I
I missed that you you've got yeah she's
got to pay this back in this time frame
and then we're we're changing directions
here yeah I mean it's either she pays up
or there's legal ramifications because
you're not touching that yeah because
then she's gonna go oh sweet that was a
free six grand I just got on that spree
yeah and she's gonna go take out a car
loan because the car is going to break
and she'll just get a note but honey
she'll pay you and there's no end to to
where this thing ends because she's got
your number she's got your ticket
and it's going to be a pain to go change
your social security number across all
of your different forms and this is and
that and that's the world you're in and
I hate that for you but it happened yeah
tough situation all right let's go to
Kevin in Denver Kevin we've got time for
a quick call here what's your question
okay guys thanks for taking the call
quick question for you so
um did an estimate with uh my tax guy
just to prepare for taxes we've we've
been blessed and income has been going
up we think we're going to have about an
eight to ten thousand dollar payment for
our taxes
um and so obviously that'll be finalized
once we get all our forms and everything
but that's our estimate
um we're in our last debt of baby step
two
um which is about 30 000 uh to pay off
original budget had that plan to pay off
by end of April
um the question is the plan I have is to
stop making payments on that
um until I have about eight to ten in
the bank just preparation for tax
payment uh we're disciplined enough to
hold that money you know we're not going
to spend it but excellent I just wanted
to get you guys take on you know is that
the right thing to do I don't want to be
in a pickle obviously for that tax bill
yes um the IRS debt is at the top of the
list when it comes to your debt snowball
and so this is your new priority is to
get this thing taken care of because you
don't want the IRS after you so I would
make it a priority to save up and if you
need to file an extension whatever you
can do to buy yourself time in order to
do this and not go over any of the
deadlines that's what you need to do so
and make sure you're working with your
taxpro to go how can I avoid ever having
a ten thousand dollar tax bill again
yeah but I love that idea if you you and
your and your wife are disciplined
enough to hang on to that eight to ten
Grand I love the idea of pausing it
stack up that cash and hopefully it
comes back and it's only six thousand
and you can dump the rest towards your
debt but that's a great idea I think
yeah and be be conservative Park more
than you need for now and then like John
said you can throw the rest of the Dead
continue on with the debt snowball uh
but man that's a tough situation it's
tax time people
hey by the way it's in April so start
now yeah you know it's coming now you
know it's coming that puts this hour of
the Ramsay show in the books our thanks
to Ben Hill running the board today
Austin Selby uh screening of the phones
and Kelly Daniel our producer we will
back be back with you before you know it
until then spend wisely save
intentionally and give generously
[Music]
hey it's Kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the Ramsey show if
you would like to do your debt free
screen live on the show make sure you
visit the ramsayshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to Nashville
and tell Dave your story
[Music]
foreign
this is the Ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions it's the Ramsay show where
America hangs out to have a conversation
about your money your career your work
your relationships your mental health
and your life I'm Ramsay personality
George Campbell joined today by Dr John
deloney best-selling author and host of
the Dr John deloney show and we are here
for you America give us a call phone
lines are open triple eight eight two
five five two two five there's no silly
questions here maybe you need some
confirmation maybe you're at a fork in
the road with your life your career
you're not sure what to do you've got a
question about budgeting about a
relationship we are happy to take your
call Tammy starts us off this hour in
Wichita Kansas Tammy welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hi there
um I have been in a long process uh
through a divorce and it was finalized
here a couple of weeks ago after
almost 27 years
um oh Danny I'm so sorry what happened
thank you
I mean
um more than one family I'm so sorry
so it's been a long two years sorry just
got choked up on that one no no no I'm
sorry that's that's a hard hard oh geez
Louise
how can we help you today I'm good
Lord's been good and faithful spells
um my question is with that
um taking care of you know finished
finally and me starting this process of
moving forward I've then
um had a career when we were first
together left that helped him with his
business had children raised
homeschooled all the way through
um just sold our property finally the
Lord said I needed to release that to
move forward so I did sold that split
off everything there was a huge IRS mess
that I discovered that I worked for the
last few years trying to get out of and
thankfully the Lord surrounded me with a
really good tax team to protect me
um so there was one year that I was
bound to
um that that came off the top of the
house being sold so everything else for
me was done individual
um so I'm not down to that and then the
rest of the house for his portion went
to go satisfy the mess that was tied to
him great so hopefully that's all done
and I will have now a nested but I'm
starting at you know 49 years old and
um
didn't finish college because started
raising my family homeschool and helping
him with his business and you know doing
that road
um so no nothing set up for retirement
nothing set up for down the road even
through working I've always been a
management or leadership or chairing
committees or fundraising even in a
volunteer world you know with you know
all the things that we were always
involved in so
um so what's your question how can we
help
I I'm trying to figure out what to do
with this check I have from my house and
then also with
um I'm getting monthly support for the
next uh probably six years okay you know
provided he doesn't fight that
um and trying to think do I go back to
school do I start a career what do I do
with this check that I'm you know down
the road I might want to buy a house I'm
renting right now for a year or two just
to let things settled good
um what's that check
um what's it worth uh right now it's 327
my only right now is about 7 300 left on
my car which I'll pay right off the top
once I cash it yeah
um
I absolutely love that you have in your
soul I'm gonna rent for a year
because the grief from this is going to
roll off of you for years right
yeah
and the what's next is Gonna Roll Off
um one of the things that I I didn't
understand this until I just sat with so
many and talked to so many
there is the devastation that somebody
that you were close to would do this
hurt you in this way right
but there's the equal Devastation and
I've heard it in a couple things you
said I even wrote them down is you don't
trust you anymore
how could I have not seen this how could
I have not done something about this
when I thought I could have saw
something right
and you mentioned in your call I'm 49 I
don't have any college degree you're
already setting up reasons why
you can't go make the back half of your
the next 50 years magical
and I need you to hear me say you got
burned you got absolutely run over
and that doesn't mean you're not worth
being well it doesn't mean you're worth
anything less in fact I want you to
stand up tall and stare this grief in
the face get some people to walk
alongside you as you walk through this
grief and it's gonna be brutal
and
you've got a year to pay your rent
hopefully that the child support I mean
the the support comes through can you
live off that support check can it pay
your rent in your bills I think so okay
yeah I think so I'll have to you know be
wise with it and thankfully throughout
the last two years of this whole process
I was getting double that so I was able
to pay down on my debt I was able to pay
off our house good good to satisfy the
IRS thing and I tried to keep some of
those Ramsey principles in my head even
though we never I I took of course he
never did you know so you can't run it
by yourself
so I tried to really focus on
improving the house getting it ready to
set the ranch it was a ranch and getting
it ready to sell and doing all that and
getting my debt down you're going to
have to grieve the sale of a ranch too
right like your whole everything's
different my Branch I sold my Ranch and
my dad died the same day oh my gosh
do you have some people you can walk
alongside here
I do I've been surrounded by amazing
people people good so Tammy do you have
any other money in savings or anything
that's the next step
um I have cash that I've been putting
aside because again I didn't know if he
was going to stop saying keep paying not
paying you know
um sold some things
um so how much cash do you have
oh gosh I was moving everything I
haven't counted it but I'm thinking
probably
maybe around 15 15 000. yeah I think so
okay so with the 327 and the 15 that
puts you in a really good spot I'm gonna
pay off this car immediately
um I'd probably just keep the 15 as an
emergency fund I'm guessing that's
that's what that would be
right that's what I was thinking so
that'll cover three to six months of
expenses for you
right and then you said you didn't have
a nest egg
do you have any retirement my the checks
on the no because I homeschooled my kids
all the way through I mean I've hey no
don't apologize for that we are oh I
don't know I am proud of it I'm good
proud of my girls I'm thankful for the
life I that I was able to do that and
pour the Lord into them no I have no
regrets on any of that I'm just trying
to be realistic about where I am now
that's right so so let's take off let's
I know this is horrible to bracket off
this this pain right this second what do
you want to do okay like what do you
want to do like and I'm asking this
intentionally like like we're like two
friends and you just won the lottery
what do you want to do what would you
love to do you mentioned management a
few times
that's what I've done all
done all that they do Driving School in
the afternoon and then I do just to get
you know I started these just to get out
of my mess and to start helping people
and working with people and I teach
Fitness classes for seniors and I love
it I love that too I can't make a living
at that yeah because of living doing
that we're going to send you a copy of
our friend Ken Coleman's brand new book
paycheck to purpose bestseller book and
it's going to walk you through I love
this stuff but how do I turn this love
into a forever job or a job a career a
calling and we're gonna send you that
book so stay on the line here and Austin
we'll get it to you yes and Tammy pay
off that debt get your emergency fund in
place you can start investing 15 of your
income and park that money in a
high-yield savings account just when
you're ready to buy it just sit on it
when that time comes thanks so much for
the call this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
if you're not using pure talk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5G coverage on
the same 5G Network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over eight hundred dollars
a year go to puretalk.com and choose the
affordable plan that's right for you
with their 30-day risk-free guarantee
you have nothing to lose go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
Ramsay to save 50 off your first month
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
season and if you're like most people
you make resolutions on New Year's Day
and give them up by Valentine's Day why
because you were trying to figure it out
on your own so if you've decided to take
control of your money this year don't do
it alone get the support and
accountability you need by joining a
Financial Peace University class you'll
go through our proven money plan with
other people who will help you stay
motivated because they're trying to get
out of debt and build wealth just like
you and right now there are hundreds of
FPU classes getting started both in
person and online so forget the lane
resolutions make 2022 of the year you
take control of your money and don't do
it alone find an FPU class and get
started for free at ramseysolutions.com
FPU that's ramseysolutions.com
FPU I'm George Campbell this is the
Ramsey Show I'm joined today by Dr John
deloney and we are taking your calls the
phone lines are open triple eight eight
two five five two two five Melinda joins
us in Cleveland Ohio Melinda welcome to
the show
hey hi thank you for having me sure how
can we help
um my husband and I are very new to the
baby steps we started the beginning of
January welcome to the gang but
thank you but we have 11 000 saved
already and from everything we've seen
Dave says to take your extra over a
thousand and put it towards your debt
which we would love to do but we have a
daughter who's medically complicated so
we never know when we will or won't be
working if she needs surgery
so we were kind of struggling as to
whether or not we should put it on the
debt or just leave it
to cover like a monthly bills if she
ends up in the hospital how much debt do
you guys have
over a hundred thousand what kind of
debt is that
about 80 of it is medical and then we
have
n car notes we don't have any credit
card debts okay what's the car worth
that has the loan on it
um
I want to say it was blue booked around
5000. okay and how much do you owe on it
about three okay
well probably not worth selling I was
just seeing if we could speed up this
process for you guys yeah
uh we brought
a hundred thousand last year okay that's
good
well I'm sorry to hear about uh your
your child with the complicated medical
situation that's a that's a really tough
thing to walk through and I know it's
scary especially with your finances
going all right what if we have to be
out of work and can't make that income
is that the biggest fear right now for
you guys
it is what's the medical competition
she has a brain
that's when we find out if we're good
for three more months or if we need to
do something
I'm so sorry how old's your baby girl
ten she's 10. I'm so sorry
do you have good health insurance or are
you having a lot of costs associated
with this or is it covered
she's had like six brain surgeries we've
already been through chemo once so
is she we're doing okay our insurance is
decent
so I I'm tempted and George step in here
I'm tempted to
sit down and look at what are the known
knowns here and you know that every
three months we're gonna have to go to
the hospital and do an MRI and here's
what that's going to cost and this is
gonna feel hard because there's so much
emotion wrapped up to your daughter into
the hospital trips and their
heartbreaking they're hard and all this
sit down and do this is hard but sit
down and do the math on this
and pull it apart from the emotion just
for a second and say each one of these
trips cost this let's make sure we have
this in an account for this year because
we know this expense is coming
and here we call it you know uh you know
during storm mode you want to pile up
cash if you know you got a baby coming
this is similar you know these expenses
are going to come
and it may even be that you sit down
with your hospital administrator and say
we know these four are coming we're
going to try to pay these out of pocket
like what would it what kind of cash
discount would you give us if we just
came and wrote you a check for this
stuff or if they're not going to do that
or if you've got to run these three you
you get what I'm get I'm driving at here
is coming up and saying these are our
knowns and then
of all of the last you know five years
you've had what six brain surgeries plus
another surgery right what do those run
yeah
yeah it's about four or forty thousand
forty thousand for her uh debulking yeah
that was her biggest one okay
man I see this more as a sinking fund
for medical costs more than I see it as
we're trying to skirt the baby steps
like John's talking about this is a
storm mode and
um you want to make sure that you're
able to get the care you need and that
you're not going deeper into debt so I'm
okay with this setting aside what I
don't want it to do is you start to this
kind of gets out of control and you just
keep saving and saving out of just fear
of the unknown because I want this debt
paid off but with medical debt the good
news is you may be able to negotiate
This and like John's saying there may be
cash discounts
um there could be hardship
um programs that you can work with that
the hospital for that you owe the money
to so I would be investigating all of my
options and really trying to fight all
this medical debt because it is one of
those debts that you can go hey I know
we have 80 grand but would you guys take
20 today right and be done with this and
in that case they may say sure we'll do
that and so if I'm you guys I'm still
gonna put as much uh put as much money
as I can on the side to pay down the
debt to cover all the health care costs
that are involved and I'm hoping this is
a season and not a lifestyle because if
it is then we've got to make some moves
we've got to still pay down this debt
you guys have a good income and so make
sure that you're doing a budget are you
currently doing a monthly budget I know
you're new to the plan
uh we actually just really started
hammering it out writing it down
everything this month it's great awesome
great well I want to gift you guys a
subscription to Ramsay plus and that is
our online membership that will walk
with you you have the every dollar plus
budgeting tool that will help you put a
plan to paper for where your money's
going it's going to give you access to
all of our courses and online content
like Financial Peace University so do
that together and maybe it'll give you
guys some hope some Vision some clarity
for what to do with your money and your
life as you move through uh This Storm
you guys are in I'm so sorry to hear
that yeah hey Melinda is is this a
terminal diagnosis here or is this just
going to be the rest of your I mean it's
gonna be years and years and years of
this
it's going to be years and years and
years of it okay so it's a it's not a
it's not a terminal diagnostic here this
is just
part of her physiology it's not terminal
yet yeah okay so yeah just like
it may be that you and your husband sit
down and say do we need to go get
different jobs do we need to go make a
different amount of money like this is a
recurring expense it's going to be a
part of our life forever what I don't
want you to do is continue to
rack up medical debt just indefinitely
you get what I'm saying
and those are hard conversations to have
but it's sitting down one of the things
the budget forces you to do is look at
the reality of the life that we're
living is this house too big is this
house too small can we afford to live in
downtown New York do we need to move to
Nebraska can we we love our jobs we make
a hundred grand is it time I go get a
different job it's going to make us more
money or you know you get I'm driving
that it's it's a truth-telling agent a
budget is yeah and if you have 11k and
you go to the hospital and say hey we
literally have 10K to our name would you
take that in exchange for this 80 000 in
medical debt they may say yes and if
that's the case I would give them that
10 grand and you will be freed up from
all of that debt leaving you with the
small car loan the student loans to
clean up and that's going to really give
you guys some peace As you move forward
because you're not going to be so
reliant on income when you don't know
anyone anything yeah maybe I've never
thought of that that might be a great a
great uh I don't say a great move but
it'd be a like take your bank statement
say this is all the money that we have
and I want to keep a thousand dollars to
make sure I can keep the lights on in my
house where you take this in exchange
for this medical debt yeah or what's the
number you give us the number that we
would like to clear this up but at the
same time you got to know that in two
more months you're going back for
another MRI three more months after that
you're coming back for another MRI so
again it's about looking at reality and
saying how does this the way we're
living match up with our financial
reality yeah
hang on our friend Austin uh screening
the phones there will pick up he'll get
you connected with Ramsay plus get
plugged into that watch the videos do
the budget I hope that gives you guys a
little bit of Peace a little bit of
control over a situation that feels out
of control right now this is the Ramsay
show
foreign
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
foreign
[Music]
foreign
welcome back this is the Ramsey Show I'm
Ramsay personality George Campbell host
of the fine print podcast joined today
by Dr John deloney best-selling author
and host of the Dr John deloney show
blinds.com 100 satisfaction guarantee
means even if you miss measure or pick
the wrong color the Remake your blinds
for free you get free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run every single month you'll save even
more use the promo code Ramsay to get
the best deal today's question comes
from Jade in New Hampshire Jade writes
my boyfriend and I do not agree on money
I'm 24 and he's 27 and we've been
together for three years we constantly
fight because he wants to spend all his
money and then my money instead of
putting some money in savings I try to
explain we need to be financially stable
by budgeting but he says we are young
and shouldn't worry about saving money
genius I've already started a retirement
account and I'm currently debt free
should we break up if we don't agree on
how to spend money money or am I being
unreasonable no you should break up
because you're married to an immature I
mean you're dating an immature child
keyword dating John there's so many red
flags here for a girlfriend and
boyfriend and he's spending her money
and they're trying to tell each other
what to do with their money and they're
trying to be financially stable my guess
is they're living together based on just
the situation right there's just a lot
of mess going on here and it's not
looking good as far as the long-term
Outlook of this relationship so let's go
through this we constantly fight
red flag I don't want to marry somebody
that we constantly fight during the
Great years when we're dating when we
both still love each other right the
honeymoon period the honeymoon we
constantly fight he spends all his money
immature child cannot does not have the
adult discipline to say hey I've
tomorrow's gonna come the month after
that's gonna come next year is going to
come I need to start planning and then
he takes your money that's red flag
number three because now he's taking
stuff that's not his and he's taking it
against
your wishes he is he is crossed he's
bashing through your boundaries
to get some of what you've already said
hey I want to plan long term I've debt
free I got retirement account and he
said I don't care what your boundaries
are I don't care what your wishes are I
want to feel good now and this is going
to come up with raising kids buying a
house living a certain town I don't care
what job you want I want to stay at home
and
run run run and then keep running you're
worth more than this Jade I gotta give
props to uh Zach running the graphics in
the booth the the lower third for this
uh question says should I dump my
yolo-minded boyfriend the answer is yes
and when you put it that way I'm just
gonna say yes without context on that
question and the key word here is
boyfriend now they're not married
there's nothing to fight for here
they're 24 and 27 you'll be okay I think
if you can't get on the same page about
your financial values you got to find
someone who does have those values it's
not even about financial advice it's
about respect and dignity yeah and this
man is not treating you with respect and
dignity respect and dignity is about
we're going to plan together so we're
going to sacrifice the YOLO now for
Safety and Security down the road it is
what do you what's going to make you
feel safe what's going to make you feel
loved and this guy cares about one thing
spending everybody's money she is 24 he
is 27 and she is still dating a child
that's not okay time to go Jade sorry
there's other men out there for you good
luck all right let's go to the phones
this hour Natasha joins us in Butte
Montana Natasha welcome to the Ramsey
Show
thank you how can we help today
or some
November of gosh last year and we lost
him in January it's been almost a year
Natasha I'm so sorry I'm so sorry what
was his name thank you George awesome
guy
yes fantastic guy how old was he
was 57. oh gosh I'm so sorry Natasha
yikes that's okay we one day at a time
that's exactly right that's exactly
right so how can we help
my mom
and
started building a house on a piece of
property uh pretty remote
um they spent five years building it
um and when I say building it I mean
building it like they hand milled every
piece of Lumber in the house wow and so
uh a true Dream Home
yes and he had always wanted to build a
house he had never built a house before
um when he passed my brothers and I and
my husband kind of helped my Mom finish
it it wasn't quite done yet she listed
it this summer and then pulled it down
emotionally it's been very difficult for
her it's worth about two million dollars
right
they've got a main house and then a
cabin in 56 Acres the house payment is
roughly 2 000 a month and she's about
200 000 in the bank okay and she just
cannot figure out what the right answer
is whether to put it back on the market
she could make it work financially to
continue making the payments she's been
doing Airbnb on the cabin on the
property
and she's looking at a long-term renter
now but mathematically
and emotionally she's having a hard time
between the two yeah
and I can't give her advice because you
know we helped yeah yeah as often as we
could
um on the build and there's a lot of him
tied up into the house so there's not a
lot there's his entire spirit is woven
into that thing literally the the nails
in that in that home were hammered by
you know what I mean he this is
different normally you you talk to
couples and they you know met with
Architects and picked out fixtures
together and and
this is different he built this thing
right
so let's take the and this is hard and
this is gonna even be offensive the way
I say this and so I apologize ahead of
time but let's take the emotion off the
table for a second
no that if I just can't do so no I got
you I got you if your mom
had the opportunity
with two hundred thousand dollars in the
bank would she buy a two million dollar
property to become a landlord and to
manage 57 acres in a couple of homes on
her own in the middle of the Wilderness
in Montana
no probably not
and so that's that to me is the answer
to the ongoing do we sell this or not is
what is the life we are trying to uphold
and
the fact right now it sounds like she's
trying to hang on to this incredible man
that built this home that set them on
the street they had plans right they had
a vision for the back half of their life
and it just it was actually going to be
a glamping and camping property of
course it was yeah it was gonna be a
mate I mean God Almighty I'm just I'm
thinking about what an incredible dream
that is
and so it's separating the fact that he
he is
deep within her in her heart he's a part
of her
at the cellular level he is not he is no
longer in this home
and it's being able to pull that apart
and say
what would he want he want me to take
the equity of his home and go live not
our Dream but what do I want to do
what's my dream going to be and so
getting her to say okay if I if he take
him out of the picture I wouldn't go buy
a two million dollar property that I can
barely barely barely afford and run it
even with it's over my head
what would I what would I do where would
I live would I go move my grandkids
would I get a condo instead and take a
wild vacation once a year what would
that look like and would my husband want
me to have two million dollars in the
bank
yeah or do you want me to manage a
57-acre property all on my own
that's the question I would ask and my
guess is he would say
oh honey take the money and go do the
thing you've always wanted to do right
he told her towards the end oh he did so
he's he's already freed her
yes yes and so the thing I always tell
folks is what's the best way to Steward
this money when somebody passes
and it sounds like as hard as it is the
ultimate outcome here will be we're
going to sell this thing if you've got a
two million dollar buyer if you've got a
two million dollar person who's willing
to take it off your hands
[Music]
yeah do something special but we gotta
have some closure here and move on
that's right and then go build a
beautiful next chapter oh I'm so sorry
we're thinking about you Gus
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
scripture of the day Colossians 3 14
above all clothe yourselves with love
which binds us all together in Perfect
Harmony
Nelson Mandela said may your choices
reflect your hopes not your fears ah I
love that it's a good one
hello good all right open phones this
hour Anthony joins us in San Francisco
California Anthony welcome to the Ramsay
show
yeah hi John how
John absolutely how can we help
yeah um I'm 29 years old I have a
girlfriend we're about the same age and
we went to basically High School
sweethearts
um but basically we're in a kind of a
hard place kind of figuring out the next
Direction within the next two to five
years
um
in terms of getting married you know
having kids in a house and all within
California but then we have our own
student debt and I have a car payment
and just kind of getting a little bit
more sense of the direction on how how
we can start to approach things okay
how much debt do you have well approach
what things approach your financial
situation or just how are you going to
build a future together are you asking a
marriage question or a money question or
both I guess it's a little bit of both
um for me it's more you know taking care
of our finances first so we've had to
talk about marriage already you know
year after year just and our
relationship's really strong but
obviously we don't want to jump into
things getting married and housing kids
right away because we're both coming out
of college debt um I guess for me I've
been a lot better in terms of paying it
down because I got a job right away
after high school and then she was
pursuing the medical field so it took
her time to get through all the
schooling and and things like that but
how long have you guys been dating
uh we just hit our 11 years few days ago
11 years and we're still just taking it
slow brother what are you waiting on
I think it's more I think we're it's
more so than the money-wise I'm
genuinely curious is it really the money
I don't know I think it's just been
difficult living in
in California
area
um trying to just trying to make the
Right Moves I mean I guess you can say
we can get married and that's do you all
live together
yes Anthony what do you
there's something there's something
bigger than this what's the hold up is
she not the one
no no definitely she's the one um we
just wanted to make sure we're
financially stapled first
um because she's coming in right now out
of college about 80k debt people get
married with debt all the time that
doesn't it's not going to affect your
marriage if you're on the same page yeah
and then you're just going to work
together and crush this thing out
there's something else here
no I think for me too because when I was
paying off my college debt it was just
hard to kind of I guess support at the
time because when she was living with me
um I was the one working trying to pay
my debt down keeping up with the
interest rate before covid you know and
then mined himself at the time bought a
25 000 car coming out of college so that
didn't help
um and then she was you know going back
to school and she didn't have a job so
I'd been kind of helping support her for
the last you know three to five years so
are you waiting until she paid gets
around to paying her debts off
I guess before we
I guess for buying a house in that
aspect but we've already talked about
um probably getting married next year in
2023 and over the so I've just saved
enough to pay off my debt and remaining
car balance um if I was to write a check
today so I've done that over the last
eight months and then I guess now that
I'm saving for a ring
um and I think I can get that in the
next three months um so it was my plan
to propose this year okay and then next
year we kind of move everything
full-fledged
um and just kind of go heads on after
that but I didn't think at the time it
was right for both of us to to come I
mean I guess we can get married like you
said but yeah um you're I mean you're
this is so much semantics right now the
only thing I'm hearing you say is you
want her to pay off her debt you you've
saved up money you've worked hard to pay
off yours is she do you not feel she's
pulling her weight
no no no no it's not that I think what
slowed it down was that when she was
still doing school after college she
wanted she wanted to be a doctor
um so after she graduated uh college she
took she took a year off because she
said College was crazy so it was fine
and then the next two years she was
going back to school to get her GPA
because when she applied to med school
she got rejected because her grades
weren't competitive so it took about two
years to take more classes she then
reapplied to med school
um at a lower level at the do level
instead of the MD level got rejected
again and you know as she's applying to
these Med schools and Cycles you it's
once a year and you don't know the
decision until the year after so that
that finally caught up to us year after
year and now that we've turned 29 and
we're approaching our 30s it's kind of
like okay let's just you know start to
get things rolling
um so she's currently working at a an
eye clinic right now full-time
um in hopes of trying to apply to PA
School a physician assistant a school
okay um well so we when we could talk
about your future here's the thing
your ball has been rolling for a long
time
a long long time with y'all want to
acknowledge it or not y'all been
together for more than a decade
and so y'all been playing house for
however many years
um you either know this is the person
I'm going to marry and I'm into this or
it's time to
move on you say you want to Merit great
that's awesome
um I would take all of the I don't know
I'm just think bro you're in
right
get going you know what I'm saying like
just get moving on down the road Anthony
I feel like you need a little gas in the
tank man like you just gotta man up
propose in the next month or two pay off
the debt today get your emergency fund
in place and when you guys are married
you can tackle her debt together you can
do it together and you're gonna be fine
but sitting around waiting and making
the well you know money's when money's
less tight maybe I'll you know maybe
I'll get around to it but that's the
problem with Playing House you don't
feel any urgency to make any real big
moves and so you kind of just Meander
through life and you look up and it's 11
years later we're like Ah that's
probably let's just get serious about
you're 29 man you act like you're going
on 50 like well time's running out so
I'm gonna sit around and keep waiting so
Anthony you're dead off today and be
debt for you today
yes will that feel good
yeah it will yes it'll feel incredible
and then can you and your wife or your
spouse or your girlfriend where can
y'all just go under the JP tomorrow and
get married
let's call it good say we'll have a
party later it's coveted season let's
save a hundred thousand dollars on a
wedding and let's just go get married
tomorrow and we'll call it good
okay so then I guess after that you know
does that mean
because I guess it was part of my
responsibility to kind of stay for a
down payment because she was going to
work on using her money today
in the singular pronoun us we there's no
like well she does the dishes and I save
up for the down payment and you guys got
to get 13 same page yes same team and
that's when you would combine accounts
that's when you set goals together you
have a vision for your life and you go
what kind of Life do we want to have
great let's knock out your debt let's
get our emergency fund in place let's
save up for the down payment on the
house let's invest 15 of our income
let's become millionaires do whatever
you want to do but you got to do it
together right now it feels like you're
kind of it's tit for Tech I had which
she took her time off I had to save up
all the money and then I had to do
that's relationship that's marriage yeah
people are struggling somebody else
lifts their arms up and then somebody
else is struggling we're there to
support each other and walk alongside
each other we're both doing great then
you can really make some progress we're
both struggling we struggle together
that's the whole whole relationship
that's what man
you don't want to say it but you don't
think she's pulled her weight over the
last 11 years financially Oh you mean so
if we just get married I just I just
gotta I gotta save up and but right now
this is a roommate with Benefits that's
yes if you're the only one working then
yes
if if she's got a full-time job
optometrist she's going to kick in too
you're both gonna pay off her debts
you're both Gonna Save up and buy this
house and if she peels off and goes back
to school she'll go back to school man
and you will help support her because
you'll be her husband
you'll be in a relationship with their
man you got to change the way you're
looking at this well I did and she'd
y'all doing this together get it man
it's a good word John can't wait to hear
more from you at uh money and marriage
it's a great pitch you and Rachel Cruz
are going to be doing that February 11th
yeah a couple weeks so go to
ramseysolutions.com it's gonna be a fun
event I'll be tuning in from home fun
show John thank you so much thank you
brother big shout out to Ben Hill
running the board today Austin Selby on
the phones Kelly Daniel a producer Brown
back there on K2 running the video side
Zack on Graphics all the crew that makes
this happen we just happen to be here
too it's been awesome thank you so much
America we'll be back with you before
you know it until then spend wisely save
intentionally and give generously
[Music]
[Music]
did you know you can listen to the
Ramsay show on your smart speaker just
tell Alexa Google assistant or Siri to
play the Ramsay Show podcast check out
all Ramsay network shows on your smart
speaker today
[Music]